that men on Batman hey man it's me Kevin
Smith and me Jason Mewes just trying to
pull solid Bobby could it's my [ __ ]
stick and right now what we're gonna do
is watch The Avengers trailer together
react to it what do they call that [ __ ]
reaction video I don't know me and Jay
are gonna watch The Avengers infinity
war trailer together now he's never seen
it right I have seen it many times and
I've cried while watching it we're gonna
watch it with this guy here you love
these Marvel movies love it I love all
of them it's blowing me away
back-to-back movies Justice League Thor
ranked Black Panthers coming out say say
Ragnarok Ragnarok Magnon Ragnarok what's
the name of the big green guy huh what's
the name of the Justice League members
got wings Oh
Hawkeye Hawkman hawk puck girl
now Hawk man what if you combine Hulk
and Hawk Hawk Hawk man ha same thing he
sounds it sounds exact same way what do
you do when you get do as this Jersey
accent alright so you love these flicks
I do
did you love you when'd you see Thor
well there's not a bet I haven't seen
but I hope we're just telling these
peoples how much you love this [ __ ]
you're like I ain't seen it yet but hey
I love my watch I am it's amazing I've
seen it twice I know I feel like a bad
person but I don't get time a person I
really haven't gone to to tell him why I
batoon half year old her name is Logan
he's got a baby girl or I'm out of town
so he's an excellent [ __ ] father I
will give it up for him for that like
maybe he missed Thor Ragnarok cuz he's
being an excellent dad but I took my kid
and
made me an excellent dad that's just my
play all right so here we go close that
door man yeah I don't have to listen to
the outside world we're gonna seal
ourselves up into a Marvel but you're
gonna turn a light on cause use more
light
there you go we were in the dark we're
in a Marvel bubble right now folks and
we're about to jump in and watch the
trailer together man here we go your
first time my first time in the Avengers
infinity Wars trailer infinity war I
keep making it plural infinity war
there's one more the truth there's
another part to this like it's a
two-parter mm-hmm and I think it's gonna
have it the other ones not gonna be
called infinity war too I think they
have a different title maybe for those
completely unfamiliar with the Marvel
world beyond the movies Thanos who
they've been teasing throughout the
movies he's their big bad in the
galaxies created by jim Starlin years
ago stano's the mad Titan possessed with
death not just the concept but the
living embodiment of death in the Marvel
Universe he tried to court her by
finding the Infinity Gauntlet collecting
the stones and remaking or destroying
the universe so they're borrowing
heavily from that and that's been the
long game story that Kevin Feige has
been telling underneath all these big
stories since iron man man slowly
building the stringing along you know
this Thanos storyline and in Avengers
first Avengers I remember I used to make
fun of it cuz like in the beginning like
Loki you know he's got the Loki pokey
stick and he [ __ ] touches you and
turns you bad and [ __ ] like that knows
it come on man I don't want to see this
comic book nonsense I just want to see
people in in costumes punching the [ __ ]
out of each other I don't know why I
drew a line with the Loki pokey stick
for some reason the mind-control Jim but
now I take it back I eat [ __ ] on
anything I ever said about the Loki
pokey stick because it's it's part of
the long game man these cats at Marvel
is genius they've been telling us story
for 10 years and we're gonna finally see
it all come together so has it been
ten years it's any er since like almost
ten years since Iron Man ten years of
goodness maybe yeah I think so
that's what I read somewhere you got
hurt you know what could be fake news
but I believe it's ten years I think I
saw somebody going like ten years of
this story it's been a while been a
while so what we're gonna do is look at
this trailer and there's a lot of fan o
Senate my friend and also a lot of what
they call the Black Order
okay black order is like the children of
Thanos so like almost on hand Proxima
midnight yeah well not like the hand
more like because the hands like
nameless faceless and in Japan soldiers
this is more like the sinister six so
fan OHS has his his the children of
things remember the believers no
remember Gamora from guardians of galaxy
yeah and who's the other one her sister
you know it's got the blue face yes I
forget her name there they were
daughters of Thanos they had siblings
like Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive
and a bunch of all these other
characters and so you heard and
guardians like that they were made to
fight each other and when they got
busted up he'd replaced in the robot
parts and so we're gonna see more of
them he's bringing the Black Order with
him on this journey we see pieces we see
a property when when somebody throws the
[ __ ] spear then you see that that's
Proxima midnight when [ __ ] I don't
wanna spoil it too much but when one of
the Avengers is down and being attacked
that's Corbin's bleep I'll call them
both out when they happen so this is and
and it's just impressive for the cluster
[ __ ] of superheroes in the trailer but
there's a few missing there's no you
don't see much or any Hawkeye and
there's no Ant Man although he can make
the argument you can't see a man he's
real small okay but but other than that
everybody's back guess who's back back
again they're all bad
Bannos back Oh
vengers back yes tell your friend all
right here we go enough entertainment
we're actually gonna watch this [ __ ] you
ready for this boy yes are you ready for
this boy I'm ready for it
make mine Marvel here we go hmm to bring
together Tony Stark remarkable
look already they're crossing over
there's dr. strange the Guam there's the
Scarlet Witch and she's looking at a
vision who looks more like Paul Bettany
sexy he [ __ ] up that vision [ __ ] I
know men s Thor oh that store right
there and then of course we've got Bruce
Banner standing next to the piece of the
armor from the Hulkbuster armor
a black widow with her hair dude
recently did her hair and then that
school
[Applause]
Tony Stark
inside inside dr. Strange's sanctum
sanctorum it's the first [ __ ]
cinematic showing of Tom Holland a
spider-man's spider-sense on his arm
there's [ __ ] Thanos his ship I think
that's what was at the end credited for
us
toilet bodies [ __ ] ever whilst he's
got that has her ass [ __ ] that's one of
the gems BAM purple Bruce Willis comes
right out that family's nothing he's not
whereas Jethro hood the other going
crazy seeded Frankie look at the
slightly super metal buddy - man that
was [ __ ] próxima - get this man a
shield bamboo Captain America [ __ ] got
the [ __ ] with the only phone we got
so exciting
whoa Buster armor Doctor Strange ah no
one's gonna win [ __ ] fight against
another one look at that Manos ticket
spider-man to the ground
[ __ ] Tony looking like here Tony took
that vision that was Corvus glaive I'm
taking the gem he's got blue gem in the
gun look at the bunch of this [ __ ] out
of the [ __ ] iron spider yeah he's got
funky there
we're gonna go Conda obviously there's
[ __ ] Falcon all-out war [ __ ] a
whole [ __ ]
[Applause]
hold on Iranian age
[Music]
no oh [ __ ]
Jordy it's the guardians of the galaxy
you there the universe is coming
together if you didn't see thor ragnarok
you won't understand i got spoiled
something for you yeah she fights hella
who is the sister the goddess of death
and she [ __ ] rips as I like oh please
them all hot Odin one out and [ __ ]
spoilers VNC Thor Iraq nerve I guarantee
all these cats dude you [ __ ] didn't
ah come on [ __ ] well you missed what
are you doing but look at show girls in
for the click baby he's like ooh let's
find out what we miss I miss nothing
that may kill thanos oh they have a
picture of Darkseid fighting thing yes
there's another video all right what did
you think I thought it was awesome I
loved so what happens when he gets all
four stones
he's unstoppable yes that these are
reshape there's five stones
you could reshape the galaxy the
universe you if you have the Infinity
Gauntlet you are God and so you he got
one stone from vision yes one stone is
from well we don't know but we don't
know but yes presumably the mind stone
that was in the Loki pokey is in visions
forehead we saw that in Avengers age of
Ultron there's one miss one stone which
i think is the space stone or the a to
come from the aether from Thor Thor to
the dark world that is where did that go
I don't know where that went
the Nova Corps has the one stone that
the guardians of galaxy that maybe the
space stone the one that he held on to
he's like we're the guardians of the
galaxy [ __ ] that stone was left with
the Nova Corps so he has to collect it
from them the eye of agamotto that dr.
strange where's oh yeah he has the time
stone in it isn't dr. strange he kept
going Dormammu and kept rolling it back
and [ __ ] and then what's the other stuff
there's Adam warlock have one in his
head no I don't think so
so they have an introduced talent yes
I've been what on the guardians of
Yahtzee I was like make mine Marvel he's
like make up Marvel so yeah they've got
he's got to collect him all but here on
earth he would get like he can't he'd
have to go to the Nova Corps to get that
one that the Guardians left and that's
how maybe they you know it's it looks
like it starts on earth and then heads
to space
what Conda they go to a condom maybe
that's where the tesseract looking yes
Loki in you didn't see Thor Ragnarok but
in Thor Ragnarok he went to the trophy
room to go get the helmet of the [ __ ]
dude who was gonna create Ragnarok but
then he passed the tesseract which was
from the Avengers and he stopped and
looked at it in that trailer they show
him holding the tesseract so they went
to a condom no [ __ ] their own space I
was thinking of getting into Captain
America 3 no no how but anyway the
implication is that Loki's stole the
tesseract and so if they're in space the
tail end credits like the first
post-credits sequence and Thor Ragnarok
they're all the Asgard was on the ship
in space and they ran into a larger ship
which I believe is that ship thanassis
shows so yeah oh my god I'm sorry just
this amazing time to be alive sauna
Bob's a Chatty Cathy age of the geek
baby warlock has the soul stone Kevin
somebody said that's uh Randall Harris
the soul stone is yeah but in the
universe does he
Jarvis vision stone is a Zed we know
that we're now a kind of stone at one
time in his head the soul stone in the
comics at one point you're absolutely
right then I [ __ ] on him I literally
[ __ ] in his mouth about that but thanks
to the internet random strangers you've
been proven right speaking of which
random strangers on the Internet any net
we're going on tour man we're heading to
Colorado you want to come see Jay and
Silent Bob live in the country where we
it is legal we're going to Colorado what
days or so we're gonna be there the
first date is December 8th and pubic
poop-poop Ludlow Pueblo in Pueblo in one
job it's so it's 8 p.m. December 8th and
then December 9th is a Hollywood
babble-on
in this same city that's right and then
we have a little evening with Kevin
Smith in Denver
I'm gonna show you together we have
December 10th we have 1 2 would you sold
out Denver all that shows sold out
whatever 11 another one on Denver's 11th
we're at the oops
where is that that is the comedy
rehearse tell you what will make it easy
go to see smart dumb I can you can find
out where the talk shows lots of shows
in Denver come to come in Colorado come
see us
we'll talk more and I will gonna have
more information to give this guy
meantime before we get out of here it's
so good we got to do it again let's
watch it again and see if we can pick up
anything here we go man REE watching The
Avengers infinity war official trailer
also causing it pausing it a man you get
a chance watch Batman ninja trailer
today we just watched that for holy-shit
and Japan they made this whole Batman
cartoon about Batman getting blasted
back to fuel Japan where he has to fight
the [ __ ] joke choker dressed like a
samurai and it's like those cool figures
action figures they're putting out now
and it's like Batman and ninja gear and
they have Darth Vader and ninja gear and
all that old-school cool Darth Vader
ain't in costume he's not but I'm just
saying the toys you know in line but
anyway it is very [ __ ] cool check it
out in any event back to this man's man
here we go
vengers infinity war trailer that's you
know what's his name to bring together
Nick Nick here clearly the hope / Bruce
Banner for food week of the sanctum
sanctorum and finally we're getting
vision and Scarlet Witch like in the
comics they're lovin that for at the end
of Thor they love the gas station Oh
Buster only and she must be on the run
maybe that's why
you see Captain America with the beard
doesn't [ __ ] beard show that's
because he's been out hiding out in
Wakanda
we'd always character sauce
see there's the whole pelvis and Tony's
on outside look what's that we're
looking out look at this look at the
spider sense it's hair standing up Peter
Parker he's gonna be part of fighting
Solomon the iron spider suit his buddies
with [ __ ] Tony Stark maybe one Tony
dies in this game there's the Sazerac
and that's panel to use this helmet legs
otherwise he looks like purple Bruce
Willis Josh soul and that's the thing
look at that [ __ ] - and so our team
incensed by the line that thought on a
midnight with the spear nobody oh yeah
which ended up in scale so Z he's
infected sorcerer supreme look the funky
[ __ ] [ __ ] black pastors in the fight
Tony's this looks like bad so Tony do it
back for this blades got a crazy [ __ ]
Jenna but we all knew that was they were
gonna come provisions we're at [ __ ]
saying now who's the gaunt little Lammy
budget [ __ ] at iron spider Bucky's ready
to [ __ ] fight black panther in the
army of the Condors ready to check to
see the whole [ __ ] room looks like
they had iron pinches
yeah you got with his beard quite with
Bucky with him on
[Music]
[Music]
manses she's part of that part of the
part of the gang now oh my god that
makes me so happy [ __ ] that's like the
best Thanksgiving anyone could ever have
seeing all that family in one place and
[ __ ] uh there it is man that's our
reaction I love this trailer obviously
I've seen it a bunch you I'm diggin I
love it again I look does it make you
want to finally go see thor ragnarok you
little [ __ ] man no I want to go out
that's not I see all grew up a Marvel
zombie and now it's just like a cam
people I see all the movies no I just
wind up seeing them on my iPad or at
home with my movie screen and stuff it's
not but again I love there's not a bad
comic book movie all the way going back
to Nick Fury's David Hasselhoff
I lost the audience yeah they're like
he's clearly out of his mind
um yes what a glorious time to be a
comic book movie fan what a glorious
time to be Marvel Studios [ __ ] man well
they're gonna make all the money you
know that's just there's two movies back
to back to shooting you know how much it
cost how much it costs to shoot down 1
billion dollars 1 billion dollars yeah
but you know how much it's gonna make 5
billion dollar again cheese becomes says
a chance to become the highest grossing
box-office earner of all time not just
domestically but worldwide cuz
everyone's involved with the story at
this point you know what I'm saying this
is like and I'm telling you dude they're
telling us in those trailers like
[ __ ] are gonna die like we're gonna
see some characters we love go down so
this movie has a chance to to take them
to number 1 spot theaters to see the
vengers whoo sorry I don't know what I'm
gonna go see this room in theater we're
gonna see it together I'm gonna wait for
you know see the whole movie while we're
watching it could be amazing
um yeah I'm gonna see it soon as
possible that's it man all right we're
gonna get out of here thanks for hanging
out with us and watching the trailer man
come see us in Colorado if you're still
inclined or New Year's Eve me and Ralph
Garman do in Hollywood babble-on at The
Improv on Melrose as well as Babylon
come come theater meeting mix allowed
there it is nuff adds make mine marvel
make muses Marvel to the new make more
money that copyright alright thanks man
thanks for hanging out bye I'm sitting
here on my birthday just trying to you
know swim in the loveliness of turning
into an old man and and Marvel decides
to give me for my birthday and they're
the sweetest people in the world
really they are I've never met any of
them but they're delightful apparently
they decided to give me an infinity war
trailer and yeah I mean it's it's funny
like it has it has things in it then I
have problems with and I've gone on
record by saying I'm not a fan of like
rings of metal in the sky I'm not a fan
of video game characters being here
antagonist that everybody's got it for
some reason or another you want a punch
in the face I'm not a fan
traditionally of giant armies of CG just
rushing at each other because I kind of
after a while the CG of it just turns
into soup and I lose the emotional
connection and at the end of the day
cinema is about connection it's about
drama is about emotion if it doesn't
have any emotional if you can't connect
to the characters who are going through
the stuff then you can't you can't feel
anything by the end of two hours and it
movie theater without emotion and yet
you know we talked about it on a reason
fat man on Batman but the thing that
Marvel's figured out isn't that these
stories are soap operas on the largest
possible scale you know it's it's dudes
TV TV is drama TV is is is long range
storytelling it's not to our chunks of
things it's I'm going to tell you the
story that could go on add in for
and in order for me to do that
successfully you need to care and and
they managed to make us care because
they've treated like a TV show instead
of treating it just like movies and so
you know just seeing seeing things like
hey it's vision but it just looks like
Paul Bettany because I'm sure he's just
advanced to the point where he's figured
out how to not look like it weird dildo
seeing things like like Natasha meeting
Bruce again for the first time since a
cobia and and what that moment must feel
like seeing you know just get that mad a
shield like son of a [ __ ] I mean you
know I think there's gonna be a loss I
mean I think at the end of the day the
thing that aside from folk Olson who
again didn't actually really die just
nobody knows that he's still alive the
multi-universe has not had a ton of loss
it's been a little bit like the
Fellowship of the Ring in that you lose
one guy and everyone else is fine
including the hobbits which seems
ridiculous when you're dealing with a
massive magical war but that's neither
here nor there it feels as if we're
going to lose him body in this one and I
do kind of feel as if if Thanos is
collecting infinity gems and the vision
has one plant that I was for head and
who knows if if Jarvis can actually hold
on to whatever passes for for corporeal
being hood without the mind gem stuck in
his forehead do we lose vision maybe
maybe you know like is there somebody
from blood commitment made yet that we
lose maybe and yet you know just just
watching the Avengers at the head of a
angry field of wakandans just marching
into battle with glee and glory of
warriors born I mean come on come on I
just man alive it's a good time to be
alive this is Kevin will always say like
they're just giving me reasons just take
a lot
[Laughter]
one more one more time once more into
the breach dear friends we go with the
Mary mortal universe you know and and
for as much as it does get to be I'm not
gonna say repetitive but the impact of
seeing all of you here is on screen
together lessons every time and because
you know once you saw the adventures
once you saw the the circle shot where
the holy [ __ ] it's everybody at once the
dream that we never thought was possible
you know once you saw the Trinity in
Batman V Superman you know once you see
a thing and that the the thing that was
important about it was seeing it for the
first time every subsequent time you
lose some impact it loses its
specialness everything you know jewels
after a while gold has lost its luster
jewel ceased to Sparkle and all that's
left is her father's love for his
daughter once you've seen that it
becomes less special and yet yet because
it's because they're know how to pull
our strings they know how to you know
how to give that speed to Nick Fury game
in the very first Avengers movie and
parcel that out over the you know that
the characters we fall in love with we
know that you know just seeing seeing
little bits and pops and watching how
people will play hopefully play in tune
into the larger into the larger sort of
thrust of the story watching Tony Stark
cradles somebody's body who I'm going to
assume as is the vision because if you
if you've got to kill anybody and it
seems that killing the thing that's not
really alive is probably if you got to
do it that's the easiest way to do it
without actually taking a real soldier
off the off the table but you know like
I yeah man I mean I'm not gonna say that
you know you roll a tear keV will say
that you roll a tear but but but for me
it just it feels like just another stop
on the train in which marvel has built
the tracks and the train just keeps on
rolling and maybe this stop is Union
Station maybe it's a big one it's not a
little baby stop it say here we are in
the big city and what's gonna happen in
the big sea
it seems as if what happens at the big
city is lots of [ __ ] will blow up a
couple of people will will fall heroes
will rise
maybe there's floating wings of crap in
the sky I don't know I mean not
everybody can sidestep that particular
Bugaboo but you know I don't know man I
don't know like Thor inside some giant
machine that seems too good lives on
lightning and I've done the biggest
thunders just a sound you know I mean
come on come on come on
Marvel faster why can't you also invent
time travel or at least just speed it up
a little bit come on so yeah I mean well
scissors say you've seen it you know
leave some comments below whether or not
you agree or whether you disagree
whether or not you feel like we're not
playing fair by calling out Marvel for
doing some the same thing that DC does
which is you know as I said giant CG bad
guy floating ring of doom in the sky
collecting of magical doodads for
whatever you know is is an affinity
gauntlet inherently better or worse than
mother boxes I don't know I don't know
feels cooler but that's just me what do
you think what do you think tell us
below but man I cannot wait for me
[Music]
you